la chine où la lente dérive de tout un
pays vers la guerre civile
la france annonce le gel de toute
relation et classieux des millions
d'iraniens saisi par la folie
l'enterrement de l'ayatollah khomeiny a
failli ne jamais avoir lieu
solidarités gagner le pouvoir polonais
apparemment s'incline mais j'arrose
health qui garde la haute main sur un
pays en quête de liberté
roland garros douché par la pluie
ces pirates et stefan edberg si avec
mancini se sont tout de même qualifiés
entre les mains bonsoir
les événements sont de plus en plus
douloureux est de plus en plus compliqué
en chine le pays est vraiment au bord de
la guerre civile
des militaires se sont sans doute battu
entre saute ce mardi d'autre part les
réactions de la communauté
internationale se multiplient dernière
en date celle de michel rocard le
premier ministre français qui a décidé
le gel des relations de tous niveaux
avec la chine nous allons revenir sur
tout cela est largement dans ce journal
mais tout d'abord l'image du jour un
pays
saisi par la démesure et l'hystérie
l'iran survolté et hors de lui pour le
dernier hommage de millions de citoyens
al-iman communie finalement lyman a tout
de même pu être inhumé jérôme baugnies
retransmission solennelle à la
télévision de téhéran du dernier voyage
de l'imam khomeiny voix étranglée du
commentateur mais les iraniens n'étaient
pas devant leur poste
des lots ce matin ils étaient venus de
tout le pays rendre hommage à la sainte
des pauvres immense marée humaine de 5 à
6 millions de fidèles
une foule comme jamais l'imam n'en avais
vus depuis son retour d'exil en février
79 prière dirigée par le grand ayatollah
golpayegani entouré du président
khameini et du fils de l'imam ahmad
khomeiny
quelques instants plus tard la douleur
éclater le recueillement fait place à
l'hystérie les fidèles entre les fidèles
ne supporte pas la séparation le
déchirement d'avec celui qu'ils
considèrent comme leur père ils se
bousculent pour toucher le linceul
cris évanouissement le deuil tournon des
mines
les funérailles doivent être interrompue
un hélicoptère arrache le cercueil à la
foule devenue incontrôlable plus tard
dépasse dharan dans un état second
empêcheront l'enterrement lui-même se
couchant dans la tombe où doit être
placé le cercueil métallique
ce n'est finalement qu'en fin
d'après-midi avec 5 heures de retard sur
l'horaire prévu que le corps sera
enterré à l'abri des regards
juste avant le coucher du soleil la loi
coranique est respectée éteignez la
lumière je veux dormir ce sont les
derniers mots de liman rapportés par sa
fille
sans doute y n'y aurait-il que le chemin
de son dernier repos serait aussi
mouvementé l'iran un pays qui a de
grosses possibilités économiques
notamment grâce au pétrole
un pays qui a une culture qui a des
traditions les un pays qui vient de
subir une terrible guerre fraticide
fratricide avec l'irak une guerre qui a
saigné le pays
alors qu'est-ce que l'iran aujourd'hui
quel état des lieux peut-on dresser au
moment de la succession de khomeini
françoise joly dans ce miroir cette
jeune femme va découvrir le visage de
son futur mariage lui aveugle la face
criblé des cas de mortier est un martyr
de la révolution
à 17 ans elle remplit sa mission pour
donner de nouvelles vies à la république
islamique
effacer les traces de dix ans de guerre
par tous les moyens le nouveau pari de
l'iran mais les séquelles sont encore
nombreuses
le chômage il frappe officiellement 15%
de la population officieusement le
double blessés de guerre s'étonne
déclare attendent que le gouvernement
lui trouve du travail
et puis la population doit aussi compter
avec 25 à 50 % d'inflation par an avec
les difficultés d'approvisionnement avec
la pénurie de logements pour ce million
de sans abri en attente d'être logés ont
fait que les produits
augmente par deux mille fois leur prix
en quelques mois et ça c'est un gros
problème pour la population avec un
rationnement qui reste au moins aussi
important si ce n'est plus que pendant
la période de guerre donc un
mécontentement populaire qui est un peu
explosif situation peut-être explosive
car il est vrai qu'une bonne part de
l'argent disponible passe en priorité
dans l'industrie pétrolière comme ici à
badens la plus grosse raffinerie du
monde réparer rapide tollé en quelques
mois mais le pétrole principale
ressource de l'iran suffira-t-il à
financer la reconstruction du pays de
quelque 12 milliards de dollars par an
pour les prochaines années ne suffit pas
à financer ses projets de développement
pour laquelle diront comme pour l'irak
d'ailleurs ont besoin de crédits
étrangers appellent à l'étranger
endettement comme par exemple récemment
avec peugeot pour la fabrication de 405
à téhéran ou bien autre solution une
indépendance économique pur et dur c'est
tout le débat qui agite les autorités
islamique l'imam khomeiny s'était bien
gardé de trancher un symbole peut-être
cet ordinateur est importé mais avant
tout calcul il invoque le nom de dieu la
chine c'est le plus grand pays du monde
il tente maintenant comme un vaisseau
sans gouvernail la chine au bord de la
guerre civile
la chine où toutes les régions se
révoltent les unes après les autres mais
il est bien difficile de savoir ce qui
s'y passe réellement
pékin a encore vécu une journée de
révolte et d'incertitudes
récit d'un mardi pékinois encore
sanglant philippe lefait
c'était il ya quelques heures alors que
la nuit de mardi vient juste de tomber
sur pékin ces images que nous venons de
recevoir confirme qu'une partie de
l'armée continue sa mission de
répression confirme aussi une situation
de plus en plus confuse pékin n'est plus
que rumeurs et informations
difficilement vérifiables pourtant
toutes font état d'une fracture dans
l'armée populaire de libération et de
combat entre différents corps d'armée
ici les soldats tirent et tuent des
manifestants là on vise une caméra
indiscrète ailleurs aux abords de
l'université de pékin notamment
on assiste à de nouvelles scènes de
fraternisation des témoins ont vu des
centaines de pékinois sortir de chez eux
pour applaudir la 38e armée elle est
supposée avoir refusé de mater la
révolte étudiante
si certains continuent de quitter
l'université de pékin redoutant un as ou
de ce qui a été il ya sept semaines le
berceau de la contestation
la grande majorité des protestataires
s'est barricadé dans le campus et s'est
installé pour soutenir le siège face à
cette situation chaotique
plusieurs ambassades occidentales ont
décidé d'évacuer leurs ressortissants ou
d'aider à certains départs c'est le cas
des américains
c'est le cas de la représentation
française à l'aéroport de pékin on fait
difficilement face à l'afflux de ceux
qui quittent le canada l'australie la
grande-bretagne ont affrété des vols
charters dans la capitale chinoise
sauvier par ce début de guerre civile
l'administration bien que contrôlée par
le parti communiste ne tourne plus qu'au
ralenti
l'agitation s'est étendue aussi à de
nombreuses villes de province comme ici
à shanghai
on y fait état de grèves de
manifestations de voie de chemin de fer
couper et de centaines de morts aussi en
tout cas dans tous les témoignages
recueillis sur place deux questions ou
et le pouvoir qui dirige la chine
voilà donc pour cette journée et pour
l'extension des troubles en province au
téléphone maintenant en direct avec nous
notre envoyé spécial que nous retrouvons
chaque soir bruno le dress bruno
tout de suite on sait maintenant qu'il
est 3 heures du matin c'est quand il est
20 heures à paris alors que se
passe-t-il maintenant ce moment à pékin
et bien aéré cette nuit à pékin je
dirais et faussement calme pour la
première fois depuis bien longtemps les
rues de la capitale ont été très tôt
déserté par la population
à 22 heures il ne restait déjà presque
plus personne dehors et les rares
pékinois plus rencontrés m'ont conseillé
d'ailleurs de ceux de rentrer rapidement
les soldats sont prêts nerveux ce soir
mais ton dit il dire sans sommation il
est vrai que la rumeur qui circule dans
la ville depuis deux jours se fait de
plus en plus insistantes
un nombre important de troupes seraient
massés dans le sud de dca et après prête
à livrer bataille à la fin de 7e armée
qui occupe la ville
les premières escarmouches aurait même
commencé selon certaines informations
alors effectivement on a entendu parler
d'affrontement entre militaires
militaire entre eux qu'est ce que qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
les buts et il est très difficile de
vérifier c'est de vérifier ces
informations
car vous l'avez compris en entendant le
commentaire de philippe lefait on ne
circule pas facilement dans la ville
surtout quand on est occidental se plier
certains en tous les cas c'est que l'on
entend régulièrement des tirs d'armes
lourdes qui ne sont évidemment pas
destinée à réprimer la ville moi même
j'ai compté une dizaine de coups de
canon au début de la nuit et dans
l'heure qui vient de s'écouler j'ai
également entendu des tirs de
mitraillette qui semblaient provenir de
l'ouest de pékin
alors vous comprenez bien que la
population est inquiète les chinois mais
aussi les occidentaux et de nombreuses
ambassades ont conseillé à leurs
ressortissants de quitter la chine
effectivement ils les étrangers sans ont
de plus en plus oui absolument je suis
allée à l'aéroport
dans sale après-midi tous les vols
internationaux étaient pris d'assaut par
des familles dont beaucoup m'ont
d'ailleurs dit être très soulagé de
quitter pékin
pour l'instant la france n'organise pas
de vols spéciaux
air france a cependant décidé de ne pas
envoyer son avion-cargo habituel pour le
prochain vol de samedi mais plutôt un
747 qui pourra accueillir environ une
centaine de passagers supplémentaires
il faut savoir qu'il est environ
boostant français qui résident
actuellement en chine dont 900 à des cas
et à cécile
il faut bien évidemment ajouter les
touristes et les hommes d'affaires dont
le nombre est difficile à évaluer
je voudrais juste ajouter pour ne pas
trop inquiéter les familles qui se
trouvent en france que pour la tension
reste chez soi ou dans son hôtel
on ne risque que tout de même pas à
grand chose merci bruno et nous vous
retrouvons bien sûr dans nos prochaines
éditions
en tout cas si les rumeurs
d'affrontements militaires entre se
confirmer ce pourrait être le véritable
début de la guerre civile l'armée bien
sûr a joué un rôle décisif dans les
événements de ces derniers jours
et pour comprendre son action il faut
savoir de quoi est faite cette armée qui
compte je vous le rappelle 3 millions
250 mille hommes au brier de l'air c'est
l'image symbole celle que retiendra peut
être l'histoire des combats qui opposent
à pékin une armée disciplinée mais
divisés un peuple
affolée mais ce hallyday pendant sept
semaines en effet la troupe chargée
d'apaiser la révolte estudiantine n'a
pas pu mener à bien sa mission
alors qu'une partie des unités se
laissait convaincre par la population de
ne pas pénétrer dans la ville les
manifestants tentaient de repousser les
convois militaires déjà parvenu à
tiananmen
si l'on a assisté à des scènes de
fraternisation entre étudiants soldats
appartenant à la même jeunesse chinoise
on voyait aussi d'autres unités conspué
et u minier ce sont ces mêmes sommes
tous membres de la 27ème armes est resté
seul dans la capitale chinoise qui
recevront samedi soir de la commission
militaire centrale dirigée par deng
xiaoping l'ordre de tirer dans la foule
son intervention brutale et meurtrière
ravivera les divisions dans l'armée
provoquant même désormais des
affrontements entre la 27e brigade
responsables du massacre et d'autres
unités notamment la 38e rester aux
portes de la capitale
c'est une situation d'affrontement entre
le 27e corps d'armée qui est seul
apparemment dans pékin et qui a provoqué
le massacre qui est commandée d'ailleurs
par un fils du chef de l'état
et puis d'autres corps d'armée qui sont
autour de la capitale dans la banlieue à
l'extérieur créée en 1927 véritablement
structuré au lendemain de la longue
marche en 1949
l'armée populaire de libération joui
pendant des années derrière mao d'un
prestige considérable auprès du peuple
une admiration et une confiance qui
commence à s'émousser au moment de la
révolution culturelle
dès son arrivée au pouvoir en 1977
d'annecy opine susi co des haines
tenaces engage des réformes qui
n'épargne pas l'armée chinoise
théoriquement garante de la stabilité
nationale c'est cette arme est à la fois
démobilisé rancunière qui se déchirent
aujourd'hui une situation qui pourrait
bien priver d'un shopping de toute
alternative à la guerre civile
après la terrible répression en chine la
france à son tour réagi le premier
ministre michel rocard annoncé tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée le gel des
relations de tous niveaux avec la chine
à la suite des événements de pékin
françois mitterrand a lui aussi évoqué
la chine tout à l'heure c'était au cours
de la conférence de presse qu'il tenait
à l'issue de son voyage officiel de deux
jours en tunisie alors je vous propose
tout de suite d'écoutés ce qu'a dit
monsieur mitterrand et ensuite nous
entendrons les propos du premier
ministre michel rocard un régime
qui pour survivre doit tirer sur la
jeunesse qui l'a formé et qui se
dressent contre lui au nom de la liberté
ce régime n'a pas d'avenir et j'ai
poursuivait en exprimant ma
désapprobation à l'égard de méthodes de
violence en souhaitant que le dialogue
est enfin sur ensto les états membres de
la communauté européenne sont à l'heure
actuelle en ce moment même en train de
coordonner leur attitude à l'égard de la
chine
et en ce qui concerne le gouvernement
français il est clair que nous entendons
gelé dès maintenant les relations de
tous niveaux avec la république
populaire de chine
voilà donc ce qu'on dit le président de
la république et le premier ministre
michel rocard georges bortoli cela
mérite une petite explication de texte
que signifie précisément le gel des
relations de tous niveaux avec la chine
comme l'a dit monsieur rocard soit une
première signification dans le langage
diplomatique c'est qu'il y aura plus d
échanges de visites officielles on ne
verra plus de ministres français en
chine
et quant au premier ministre chinois
monsieur li ping qui étaient
officiellement invités à venir en france
avant la fin de l'année ben disons qu'il
est des invités ce n'est pas une rupture
des relations diplomatiques en retire
page
les ambassadeurs mais l'idée c'est qu'on
ne peut plus parler à tous les niveaux
au président de la république ou
ministre ministre on ne peut plus parler
avec des dirigeants chinois qui font
tirait sur leur propre peuple alors ça
n'a pas de signification économique de
signification sanctions économiques
directes mais il me semble que dans un
pays comme la chine où l'économie est
encore très centralisé très étatisée
disons ce refroidissement des relations
politiques ne peut avoir que un effet de
refroidissement sur l'est les
investissements disons français est
d'ailleurs bien avoir un exemple qui
concerne la communauté ce matin à
bruxelles monsieur de l'heure le patron
de la communauté a refusé de recevoir un
ministre chinois et de fait il a ainsi
gelé les
négociations commerciales entre la
communauté européenne et la chine
alors hier des mesures de george bush
aujourd'hui les mesures de la france de
la communauté vela n'ai pas l'impression
tout de même que toutes ces mesures sont
un peu dérisoire face à un pays si grand
et si complexe
écoutez on ne sortira pas si c'est un
gel des investissements étrangers en
chine le sentira pas au fin fond d'un
village du sichuan n'est ce pas mais il
y a tout le côté chine moderne chine qui
se modernise à toute allure c'est très
visible dans les grandes villes d'une
modernisation qui a été voulait
justement elle l'a quand même apporter
un mieux-être important au niveau de vie
a doublé en dix ans ça c'est fait grâce
à des capitaux étrangers grâce à la
technologie étrangère
donc c'est un secteur où les chinois
sont particulièrement vulnérables et je
disais et je dirais même qu'avant toute
idée de sanction économique appliquerait
les européens et les japonais les
chinois d'extérieur de hong kong et des
rats le gouvernement chinois s'est auto
sanctionné lui même car les
investisseurs étrangers quand il voit
les images qui vient de chine
quel peut être leur réaction sinon la
prudence merci georges et puis pour
terminer ce chapitre sur la chine cette
belle initiative des avocats il lance
une opération 10000 avocat pour la chine
ses avocats français propose que chaque
chinois blessés ou arrêtés soient prises
en charge par un avocat en france ou en
europe un avocat qui assurerait le suivi
de dossiers avant tout cela bien sûr en
liaison avec les associations chinoises
des droits de l'homme et déjà de
nombreux avocats européens ont répondu
positivement à cette initiative le
triomphe de solidarité aux élections
polonaises c'est une situation
complètement nouvelle qui est maintenant
instauré en pologne le pouvoir c'est à
dire le parti communiste a reconnu sa
défaite et semble joué le jeu en
acceptant de partager les
responsabilités avec solidarité alors
sur cette déroute du pouvoir la première
de cette ampleur dans une démocratie de
l'est les explications de notre envoyé
spécial à varsovie
jacques merlino
le raz-de-marée solide 1h et symbolisé
ce soir à varsovie par ces grands
panneaux où s'additionnent les noms des
élus sur la place de la constitution
chacun peut alors prendre conscience de
l'ampleur du succès un succès tel que
contre toute attente solidarnosc à deux
ou trois voix près et maintenant en
position de choisir le prochain
président de la république tout ce qui
se présentait sur les couleurs du parti
communiste le réveil est brutal
grégory to direct est de ceux là nous
l'avions suivi la semaine dernière il
était alors si sûr de triomphe et qu'il
se ferait le luxe en pleine campagne
électorale de jouer au tennis
aujourd'hui il cherche à comprendre je
pense que c'est une bataille perdue mais
pas une guerre perdue
il nous faut maintenant réfléchir
tranquillement sur les causes et les
conséquences du choix des électeurs
la coalition ne s'attendait pas ni celui
d'un match à une telle victoire
aujourd'hui des deux côtés
nous sommes en état de choc il nous fut
manifesté aucune émotion répondait
collège valaisanne sinon il n'y aura
plus jamais d'élections libres car le
pouvoir dira que nous ne sommes pas
responsables
le jld ans maintenant est de redresser
la situation économique
après un long délai de réflexion
le pouvoir a reconnu sa défaite et a
publié un communiqué appelant à la co
responsabilité dans la conduite des
affaires du pays
en clair cela signifie que le
gouvernement polonais qui s'engage à
poursuivre la voie démocratique et cela
malgré son échec électoral et qu'ils
proposent à solide hanoch de forme et
maintenant ou plus tard un large
gouvernement d'entente nationale
enfin à l'est toujours mais beaucoup
plus à l'aise cette fois les nouveaux
troubles en ouzbékistan une région
d'union soviétique qui se trouve dans la
partie asiatique de l'union soviétique
il y a eu des affrontements entre
ethnies différentes
les ouzbeks contre les meskhètes
l'origine turc
il y a eu des dizaines de morts et 200
blessés le week-end dernier un nouveau
problème régional très sérieux pour
mikhaël gorbatchev
la fin de cet important chapitre
étrangers l'actualité politique en
france c'est d'abord le débat sur la
motion de censure à l'assemblée une
motion déposée par l'opposition rpr udf
contre la politique d'immigration du
gouvernement à l'instant même j'apprends
que comme prévu le gouvernement n'a pas
été censuré la motion déposée par
l'opposition n'a recueilli que 264 voix
au lieu des 289 nécessaires en tout cas
ce débat était l'occasion d'un
affrontement des ténors de la chambre
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing qui a
ouvert compte rendu de pascal guimier il
faisait un de ces temps à ne pas mettre
un député dehors malgré tout l'offensive
de l'opposition n'a pas vraiment fait le
plein des troupes cet après-midi censure
udf rpr giscard premier de cordée piques
contre laurent fabius son rival aux
européennes avant une critique sur le
fond pour vge immigration rime bien avec
élection je ne souhaite pas qu'on fasse
jouer aux immigrés le sort qu'ont
réservé jadis au débat sur l'école
privée une arme de division qu'on
ressent lorsque les autres sont
émoussées passage de relais et second
coup de boutoir jacques chirac loi de
circonstance arrière-goût idéologique
arrière-pensées électorales le président
du rpr désigne herman sa cible dans
cette affaire la responsabilité de
monsieur mitterrand est entière et l'a
entendu seul imposé à tous une
conception personnelle de la situation
des étrangers en france en réponse
l'ironie dans louis mermaz européenne
encore pour le président du groupe
socialiste
la motion de censure ne cache pas que la
liste d'union n'arrive pas à décoller
européenne toujours c'est enfin michel
rocard qui évoque une certaine tournée
électorale de giscard et chirac en au
vernis vont célébrer la victoire de
l'identité française à gergovie ses
supposés sa défaite à les y a quelques
mois plus tard
le dos que de marcher sur les brisées de
l'extrême droite vous feriez mieux de
chercher quand le génie national ce qui
fait sa grandeur et son universalité
bref échange de bons procédés à chacun
ses arrière pensées
les députés viennent de finir de voter
le résultat s'annonce sans surprise ce
n'est pas ce soir que le gouvernement
sera renversée où l'on reparle de la
sphère boutboul d'art ibhunu la femme
jockey et sa mère ont de nouveau été
entendu et placé en garde à vue par les
policiers cette fois il ne s'agit pas de
l'assassinât jamais élucidé de jacques
perron le mari d'harry boutboul les deux
femmes cette fois ont été entendues dans
le cadre d'un autre assassinat celui de
bruno d'assac un représentant de
commerce qui avaient des liens avec le
milieu
rappel des deux affaires rémy roches
brunes ou d'assac dont le corps a été
repêché en mai 88 dans un bassin du port
du havre n'était pas mort
accidentellement
il avait été abattu d'une balle de 357
magnum
sa voiture avait été retrouvée à
proximité incendiés et d'un sac n'était
pas simplement le vrp tranquille que
certains croyaient il menait une double
vie qu'il a menée semble-t-il à
fréquenter assidûment les cercles de jeu
le milieu des courses et le milieu tout
court c'est dans le cadre de cette
affaire de meurtre que d'arrêt boutboul
et sa mère elizabeth compte boutboul
sont actuellement entendues à paris par
des policiers de roi on se souvient
qu'en décembre 85 l'époux de dari
boutboul l'avocat jacques perron avait
été abattu dans son immeuble un ordre de
professionnels qui n'a jamais été
élucidé
mais l enquête avait mis en lumière
l'univers singulier de la famille
boutboul
un père qui se fait passer pour mort une
mère à la tête d'une grosse fortune
ancienne avocate radiers à la suite
d'une escroquerie au détriment d'une
congrégation religieuse
l'audition d'aujourd'hui de la mère et
de la fille boutboul doit-elle laissé
penser que les deux affaires sont liées
certaines rumeurs font état de relations
ou même de rapports professionnels entre
d'hassaké les deux femmes mais dans les
milieux proches de l'anc est on indique
qu elles ne sont entendus qu'au titre de
simples vérifications
et pourtant lors garde à vue pourrait
être prolongée de 24 heures bien
compliqué deuxième affaire juridico
mondaine encore la sphère joffo demain a
lieu la vente des bijoux dont le célèbre
coiffeur avait été accusé de recel mais
maurice joffo a provoqué tout à l'heure
un coup de théâtre
emmanuel magne et un visiteur pas comme
les autres cet après midi à l'hôtel
drouot
c'est maurice joffo lui même qui vient
voir son ancienne collection de bijoux
ici sont exposés tous les pierres les
bracelets les pendentifs c'est il ya
quatre ans par la justice novembre 84
maurice joffo est arrêté puis inculpé de
recel de vol aggravé il est présenté
comme le receleur du siècle tous ces
bijoux et les auraient achetés à des
truands octobre 86 le procès maurice
joffo est condamné à cinq ans ferme
le tribunal a précisé qu'il n'avait pu
fournir aucune facture les aujourd'hui
même à la veille de la vente de la
collection par les douanes le
mont-de-piété a convoqué maurice joffo
dans leurs archives ils ont retrouvé la
facture concernant la plus belle pièce
de la collection
cette pierre de près de 13 carats vendue
tout à fait légalement à maurice joffo
en 1976 on m'a condamné et dans mon
procès verbal le condamnation autrement
dit la grosse tête messieurs joffo
n'ayant pu fournir aucune facture on lui
saisissent les bijoux or j'ai une
facture pour chacun de ces objets pour
chacun de ces objets et puis je défie
qui que ce soit de trouver un bijou volé
les cigares achetés non monsieur ne peut
plus permettre de racheter
on peut pas racheter en une journée ce
qu'on a mis 40 ans pour acheter l'avocat
de maurice joffo a réuni les factures de
la plupart des bijoux qui seront vendus
demain des factures qui n'ont pas été
présentés lors du procès pour une raison
que l'on ignore
il est trop tard pour tenter d'arrêter
la vente maurice joffo a donc décidé
d'introduire une action pour demander la
révision de son procès à l'instant même
le verdict
pascal d'olic vient d'être condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
assortie d'une peine de sûreté de 18 ans
par la cour d'assises de l'oise pascal
d'olic vous en souvenez c'est ce boucher
de 29 ans qui était inculpé de six
assassinats par dépit amoureux
les jurés lui ont refusé les
circonstances atténuantes
d'autres informations importantes de ce
jour tout de suite avec éric perrin est
tout d'abord la décision du premier
ministre michel rocard à propos de
l'armée on va examiner de près le coût
des programmes de défense et surtout on
va réduire le nombre d'essais nucléaires
dans le pacifique
michel rocard décide de réduire le
nombre des essais nucléaires français
dans le pacifique
le premier ministre a par ailleurs
annoncé un audit sur les coûts des
programmes militaires réalisées avec des
cabinets privés cet audit devra examiner
quelques programmes passés et évaluer
les procédures d'exécution des
programmes futurs
treizième succès consécutif pour argane
le lancement initialement prévu pour le
26 mai avait dû être reporté à la suite
d'un incident technique
la fusée européenne a finalement mis sur
orbite c'est cuit deux satellites l'un
japonais l'autre ouest allemand prochain
vol
le 23 juin
le rejet de gaz radioactif dimanche
dernier à la centrale nucléaire de
tricastin était bien accidentelle le
fcpr y précise aujourd'hui que cet
incident est sans conséquence pour les
habitants et l'environnement
commémoration du 45e anniversaire du
débarquement en normandie la reine mère
d'angleterre qui participé
personnellement à la cérémonie a
inauguré une stèle à la mémoire de tous
les alliés qui ont participé au
débarquement de nombreux véhicules
d'époque se sont rassemblés pour une
reconstitution du jour j quelques
résultats de sport d'abord du cyclisme
avec laurent fignon toujours maillot
rose du tour d'italie après la 17e étape
c'est phil anderson qui a remporté cette
étape
et puis en football le racing reste en
première division sous l'appellation de
racine pas rien à la place donc du matra
racing mais le club jouera bien en
première division
et puis le tennis c'est bien tout de
suite nous retrouvons jean ma mère à
roland garros mon cher jean
contrairement à hier les cas x sont fait
respecter aujourd'hui
oui il faut dire qu'il y avait peu de
rencontres disputées en raison de la
pluie vous ne l'ignorez pas mais
effectivement la logique était respectée
donc steffi graf numéro un mondial
qualifié et stefan edberg numéro trois
mondial qualifié également mais je vous
le disais la vraie vedette aujourd'hui
ça a été sans aucune sans aucun doute la
pluie qui a interrompu toute la journée
le camp des partis sans cependant
fausser le résultat final quelques
quarts de finale ont donc eu lieu
notamment stefan edberg au service ici
opposé avant civil argentin mansigné
numéro 13 mondial qui n'a pas pu grand
chose aujourd'hui face à un très bon et
bergues le plus belle volée de ce roland
garros 1989
même s'ils l'emportent en trois sets ed
baird a eu du mal à conclure le dernier
mancini est un joueur très physique il
pensait sans doute rester plus longtemps
sur le court
une tactique que visiblement fr foule et
éviter et berg est donc le premier
qualifié
pour les demi finales de roland garros
quant à steffi graf sans battre un
record de rapidité elle n'a pas traîné
un premier set expéditif un deuxième un
peu plus poussive sans doute gêné par
les retards est due à la pluie
mais ce n'est pas aujourd'hui de toute
façon que steffi graf s'est beaucoup
dépensé alors il ya tout de même peu de
qualifier hervé pour les demi-finales
pour l'instant chez les féminines
arantxa sanchez l'argentine s'est
qualifiée en ce moment-même mary joe
fernandez l'américaine est opposé à quai
les i elle a remporté le premier set et
elle est à égalité avec la canadienne
dans le deviennent monica seles la
yougoslave joue contre la bulgare mme
aliyeva un set à zéro en faveur de seles
et chez les hommes est bien en ce moment
boris becker sur le central où on est
opposé à bergères
il a pris le premier set et il mène 5-3
dans le deuxième
une rencontre qui à mon avis ne sera pas
terminée avant la nuit il en sera de
même sans doute pour l'une des deux
rencontres féminines notamment mary joe
fernandez et kelesi qui sont assez
proches l'une de l'autre dans ce
deuxième set
mais si j'en ai bien sûr tous les
résultats dans morceaux choisis tout à
l'heure avec christian quidet voilà il
me reste à vous donner les résultats du
tiercé le tiercé fait 8 19 9142 30 50
dans l'ordre 823 30 50 dans le désordre
tout de suite la météo avec sophie
davant dernières éditions henry c'est
nier vers 23h20 demain télé matin 6h30
attention dans télématin spécial bac en
direct du lycée carnot avec avec à 8h25
chantal kimmerlin qui donnera aux
parents tous les sujets sur lesquels
leurs enfants sont en train de plancher
histoire sans doute d'accroître leurs
angoisses
voilà et puis 13 heures comme chaque
jour patricia charnolé william leymergie
à demain 20 heures
bonne soirée